drowsy driving could be responsible for
thousands more deaths on us roads every
year than first thought new research out
from triple-a overnight says drowsiness
could play a part in nearly ten percent
of all crashes in last month 29 percent
of drivers admit to being behind the
wheel when they had a hard time keeping
their eyes open Kris Van Cleave is on
the road in Washington with the dangers
Kris good morning well good morning
researchers and police have long
suspected that drowsy driving was an
underestimated underreported factor in
crashes now the CDC says the average
adult needs at least seven hours of
sleep at night many people don't get
that much sleep and here's where that
can be dangerous researchers have found
that if you're a drowsy driver on just
four hours of sleep you could be as
dangerous as a drunk driver when police
in Addison Illinois pulled over the
driver of this pickup he said he was
coming off a 14-hour shift and was
exhausted that driver got a warning
it just never dawned on me that we would
lose her but a drowsy driving crash
killed Jennifer Pierce's 18 year old
sister Nicole the Virginia Tech freshman
was coming back from a ski trip with
four friends when the driver fell asleep
and slammed into a tree for ten years
we've had to deal with her loss and not
just the loss of who she was at 18 but
the loss of the many years and who she
would have become this teen was asleep
behind the wheel when he rear-ended
another car no one was hurt triple-a
researchers studied videos like these
from cameras mounted in cars of 3500
drivers looking for signs of fatigue
federal estimates cite drowsiness as a
factor in one to two percent of crashes
when researchers analyzed more than 700
crashes caught on tape they found signs
of drowsy driving in roughly 10% one in
10 one in ten that's a lot of crashes
definitely William Horry is from the
triple-a foundation for traffic safety
there's really no truly effective
countermeasure to drowsiness as asleep
it really comes back to trying to plan
and give yourself enough time to get
that sleep now if that's seven to nine
hours of recommended sleep sounds like a
luxury some things to keep in mind
researchers say the most dangerous times
to drive drowsy or overnight and things
to look out for e if you're having
trouble maintaining your lane keeping
your eyes open or don't remember the
last few miles you've driven those could
all be signs you are too tired to be
behind the wheel go home and go to bed
seven to eight hours sounds like a dream